les dames et messieurs mes chers amis je
voudrais d'abord je suis sûr vous le
comprendrez cher pierre exprimer ma très
ferme condamnation des événements
scandaleux auxquels nous avons assisté
hier à paris
je pense notamment à ce qui s'est passé
à l'hôpital necker ce qui est un
scandale lorsqu'on sait que ce jeune
enfant de 3 ans étaient hospitalisés
qu'on puisse attaquer un hôpital pour
enfants est un scandale le gouvernement
français a perdu toute forme d'autorité
les débordements sont quotidiens
les blocages sont intolérables et
exaspère les français je demande que
soit engagée la responsabilité civile et
financières de la cgt qui organisait la
manifestation que chacun maintenant
rennes ses responsabilités c'est trop
facile on appelle à manifester le
spectacle donné par la france est
lamentable en pleine organisation de
l'euro et bien que les organisateurs
assume la responsabilité
ça s'appelle la responsabilité civile je
demande par ailleurs l'incarcération
immédiate et le rétablissement des
peines planchers automatiques contre les
casseurs contre les voyous qui ont donné
un spectacle intolérable de la capitale
de la france
et naturellement je vous demande que
nous rendu hommage à ces deux policiers
sauvagement assassinée nos pensées vont
à leur jeune fils quels débuts dans la
vie à leurs proches à leurs collègues
que les choses soient claires les
républicains sont aux côtés des forces
de l'ordre
nous soutenons la police de la
république et la gendarmerie nationale
je souhaite dans la lignée d'ailleurs ce
qu'a très bien dit eric ciotti que soit
désormais prises les mesures
d'assignation à résidence et de
rétention pour les individus soupçonnés
d agissements les plus dangereux qu'on
arrête de nous rebattre les oreilles
avec le principe de précaution
lorsqu'on n'est pas capable d'appliquer
le principe de précaution à la sécurité
des français
si quelqu'un est en lien avec des
activités terroristes
il doit être assigné on doit lui connaît
un bracelet électronique est en tout cas
on doit protéger les français
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
par ailleurs tous les étrangers sur le
territoire national où tous les doubles
nationaux qui sont convaincus d'avoir
des liens avec une activité terroriste
nous demandons leur expulsion immédiate
du territoire national maintenant ça n'a
que trop duré que le gouvernement de la
république prenne enfin ses
responsabilités
dois-je rappeler une nouvelle fois que
de mon point de vue il ya mieux à faire
que d'utiliser les policiers les
gendarmes les crs et les gendarmes
mobiles à contrôler des fans zone alors
que la sécurité des français se trouvent
à ce point engagé
si vous le voulez bien avant de
poursuivre je vous demanderais puisqu'il
est pratiquement me dis que nous nous
fassions minute de silence à la mémoire
de ces deux policiers si courageux
côté jour merci et d'ailleurs je vous
remercie aussi pour la profondeur de
cette minute de silence qui montrent
combien comme tous les français vous
avez été bouleversée et vous avez raison
bon la transition sur elle n'est pas
facile mais enfin
d'abord merci à tous ceux qui ont
participé à cette convention autour de
pierre lellouche d'eric woerth de joël
da l'inde parmi les experts de renault
17 juin de ses électeurs
un de ses lecteurs attentifs électeurs
pas encore on sait jamais alors je
voudrais essayer de vous dire les choses
plus franchement le moins augmenté cible
et surtout d'une façon la moins
théoriques possibles
la première chose c'est que le monde
dans lequel nous vivons n'a jamais été
si complexe c'est une donnée que vous
devez avoir présent à l'esprit
je ne dis pas pierre que c'était facile
au moment de la guerre froide
je ne dis pas que c'était facile au
moment il n'y avait qu'une seule grande
puissance jeudi que la multipolarité du
monde d'aujourd'hui et les menaces
multiples qui vont avec la multipolarité
n'a jamais rendu
le monde aussi complexe aussi
imprévisible avec des foyers de menaces
et de crise aussi diverses
il y avait une possibilité de grille de
lecture dans le passé alors il pouvait y
avoir chez renault une école contre une
autre mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
possibilité de grille de lecture
si ce n'est la multipolarité elle multi
occasion de crises diverses le monde est
instable et fragile ya le retour de la
russie
est ce que c'est moi qui est un fait
politique qu'on peut soutenir obama va
si on voit pas qu'il ya un retour de la
russie
on peut dire que la fin du 20ème siècle
s'est traduit par un effacement de ce
qu'on appelait l'union soviétique
que le début du xxième siècle se traduit
par un retour de la russie
si on ne le voit pas c'est qu'on n'a pas
la même grille de lecture du monde il y
a
les nouvelles ambitions de la chine
parce que jusqu'à il ya quelques années
la chine refusait d'assumer la moindre
responsabilité internationale se
consacrant sur sa situation intérieure
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils refusent
c'est qu'ils revendiquent notamment
d'être une puissance monétaire depuis
les fameuses déclarations du président
clinton à l'époque et la nouvelle
ambition de la route de la soie
qu'est ce que c'est si ce n'est une
volonté clairement assumé personne ne
l'ont fait leurs proches de la chine
d'assumer des responsabilités c'est un
fait nouveau un rien que ces deux
phrases montrent qu'on est dans un
contexte géostratégique qui a
complètement changé
l'émergence de l'asie écoutez il ya sept
milliards d'habitants sur la planète y
en a quatre en asie
quand on sait que c'est la démographie
qui fait l'histoire et pas l'histoire
qui fait la démographie on comprend que
l'émergence de l'asie
l' axe central du monde s'est déplacé
d'un axe occidentale d un axe asiatiques
je ne dis papa c'est un vrai plaisir je
le dis parce que c'est une réalité donc
il nous faut tenir compte
l'acce du monde aux 19e et d'ailleurs
jusqu'à quasiment les deux tiers du 20e
c'était un axe occidental pour faire
clair européen états unis malaxe du
monde en ce début de 21e siècle il est
asiatique et la question qui se pose est
ce qui sera africain et asiatique whisky
sera africain à la place de l'asic
en tout cas nous les européens qu'elle
vous additionnez les américains on
représente à peine 10 % du monde et
profitons-en puisque à horizon de 30 ans
sera moins de 10% du monde vous avez les
chiffres le décollage de l'afrique c'est
moi la fin du xxème siècle n'était
qu'une longue description des raisons
pour lesquelles l'afrique s'enfonçait
famines épidémies guerres il ya un
décollage africain qui n'est pas
suffisant compte tenu de la pression
démographique mais qui est incontestable
est par ailleurs il ya aussi l'émergence
de l'amérique latine
alors je connais bien la situation du
brésil
aujourd'hui on peut pas considérer dans
l' équilibre du monde des pays comme le
brésil l'argentine ou la réussite assez
exceptionnel de la colombie et du chili
sont des éléments majeurs dont on
n'avait absolument pas la moindre idée
il ya 15 ans voilà c'est donc complexe
et donc nouveau c'est donc fragile
à ceci s'ajoute la guerre à la
civilisation engagé par un islamisme
radical et je me demande encore bien
pourquoi comment il peut se il ya voir
le chef de la première nation du monde
qui a du mal à prononcer le mot
islamisme radical
enfin franchement enfin pardon dieu je
suis un militant convaincu de de l'axé
atlantique
parce que vous savez très bien que pour
moi l'histoire ça compte comme pour toi
mon cher pierre et qui n'est pas
absolument de questions alors même que
l'occident bien minoritaires de se
séparer des américains mais enfin peut
on peut avoir une alliance stratégique
avec les américains est quand même
étonné qu'on ne veuille pas désigner
l'ennemi
enfin c'est exactement un médecin qui
dirait un patient écoutez le diagnostic
n'est pas bon mais je ne veux pas nommer
la maladie a bomb si vous ne met pas la
maladie comment vous l'a guéri c'est si
vous ne posez pas un diagnostic comment
vous arrivez à trouver un remède
donc il faut il ya une guerre une guerre
qui est fait à la civilisation et cette
guerre est faite dans les djihadistes
qui se nourrissent d'une idéologie et
l'islamisme radical
et ça c'est un point très fort est ce
qu'on est capable d'affirmer cela sent
le moins du monde se livrer je ne sais
quelle dénonciation nos compatriotes
musulmans qui n'ont rien à voir avec
cela mais c'est une réalité
alors face à ce monde
il n'y a jamais eu autant besoin de
leadership jamais et on en a jamais
autant manquer bon oil leadership en
syrie cinq années de guerre civile
ouais leadership face à l'état islamique
quelques milliers de barbares et les
pechmergas montre que quand enfin je
veux dire les kurdes que quand on est
déterminés parce qu'en plus ce sont des
lâches
il fuit sans combattre parce que la
réalité elle est là
walt leadership pardon dans ce drame qui
est l'affrontement entre chiites et
sunnites qui est un drame absolu parce
qu'ils alimentent temps de conflit dans
la région
walt leadership quand le la paix entre
israéliens et palestiniens n'a jamais
semblé aussi éloignées cannes leadership
voile leadership eux quand la première
puissance mondiale les états unis se
détournent de régions où leur influence
est pourtant décisif parce qu'ils ont
trouvé du gaz de schiste
excusez moi ya pas que le gaz de schiste
il n'y a pas que le pétrole est aussi
les convictions well leadership
quand l'europe cède au chantage turcs
parce que c'est un chantage de monsieur
erdogan sur les migrants si rien d'autre
cela il faut employer les mots tels
qu'ils sont walt leadership sur la
question ukrainienne 18 mois pour aller
parler les yeux dans les yeux avec le
président poutine 18 mois alors après on
peut être d'accord pas d'accord on peut
dire tout ce qu'on veut
normal à 18 mois well leadership well
leadership sur la question de la russie
à force de ne plus vouloir parler avec
la russie pierre a raison on est en
train de laisser s'installer ce qu'il
faut appeler une nouvelle guerre froide
qui ne sert l'intérêt de personne
certainement pas des ruches c'est
certainement pas de l'europe voilà l'art
et la réalité du monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
aucun leadership well leadership en
afrique ça m'intéresse de le connaître
l'afrique va connaître mes chers amis le
plus grand choc démographique de
l'histoire de l'humanité
tout le monde se passionne pour le
changement climatique
nous n'avons connu que cela je ne
reproche pas qu'on se passionne pour le
changement climatique naturellement mais
nous n'avons connu que cela est bien
avant que l'industrie existe c'est bien
l'arrogance humaine que le pensaient que
les changements climatiques dépendent de
nos mais peu importe je la coop 21 je
suis pour mais l'afrique va connaître le
plus grand choc démographique de
l'histoire de l'humanité
il n'y a aucun leadership aucune
organisation internationale qui se
préoccupent de cela d'une afrique qui va
doubler de population en 30 ans qui est
quand même un élément essentiel
alors où est le leadership sur la
réforme de la gouvernance mondiale où
est il
la gauche la réforme est totalement
bloquée personne n'en parle
les solutions n'ont jamais été aussi
éloignées alors la voix de la france
dans cette absence de leadership
moi je veux pas faire de politique
politicienne sur les étranges affaires
est une tradition française de
continuité non 20 quand même jamais je
n'aurais lycée madame merkel négocier ce
n'est que monsieur erdogan
jamais je vous le dis comme ça le corse
ce n'est pas l'idée que je me fais de la
conduite de la france schengen est par
terre depuis deux ans où sont les
propositions françaises
le dialogue avec là aussi il n'y en a
pas le règlement sur la question
ukrainienne on n'a pas le l'effroyable
drame syrien
j'y reviendrai personne n'en parle et la
voix la france est tellement affaiblie
que quand monsieur obama bientôt en
europe
il considère qu'il ya deux capitales qui
compte londres et berlin
ils ne s'arrêtent même pas à paris je
puis vous dire que je n'aurais pas
accepté cela
parce que c'est bien beau de dire que la
france est un allié fidèle des états
unis un allié fidèle ça doit être
respectée quand on ne s'arrête pas à
paris on ne respecte pas notre pays
ce que je dis pierre n'en n'est pas du
tout une attaque pour eux ou qui que ce
soit
c'est simplement un problème de principe
je ne dis pas du tout que la diplomatie
française n'a pas fait les choses utiles
depuis quatre ans je pense qu'elle ait
eu raison d'intervenir au mali je pense
et nous l'avons dit cher pierre que ça a
été une bonne chose
le relèvement significatif du niveau
d'exigence de l'accord nucléaire iranien
même s'il y avait bien des progrès à
faire je ne critique pas même
même quand ils ont un peu ici entre pas
lycéens israéliens
simplement nous avons un désaccord
frontal
monsieur hollande et moi c'est que je
considère que la vocation de la france
c'est d'être un leader
parce que pour moi la france n'est pas
un suiveur
la france a vocation s'est porté une
grande ambition
alors le défi de l'énergie c'est
d'emmener les autres avec soin au mali
on en met personne en centrafrique ont
emmené personnes et dans le meilleur des
cas on se retrouve tout seul je rappelle
qu'en côte d'ivoire
nous avions la totalité de la communauté
internationale avec nous je veux dire
d'ailleurs un mot de la libye parce que
c'est un sujet qui me tient très à coeur
et comparer avec ce qui s'est passé en
syrie parce que j'en ai assez que quand
on ne connaît pas une situation n'en
parle avec beaucoup d'autorité
je le prends deux minutes que vous
expliquer les choses ont peu à l'infini
débattre de la légitimité ou de
l'utilité d'avoir été en afghanistan au
koweit
à l'époque de monsieur mitterrand mon en
irak n'est pas de je comprends les
données du débat je je je les accepte
bien volontiers
vous ne pouvez pas je vous dit vous ne
pouvez pas avec toutes les convictions
qui sont les miennes
vous posez la même question s'agissant
de pays qui bordent la méditerranée la
syrie c'est la méditerranée la libye
c'est la méditerranée la méditerranée
ailier parce que la méditerranée au plus
large ses 16 100 kilomètres en plus
courts ses 14 kilomètres
donc on ne peut pas raisonner en terme
d'intervention de la france à l'étranger
de la même façon lorsqu'on est en
méditerranée où lorsqu'on est aux
confins du monde c'est pas la même chose
j'évolue l'intervention avec cameron
avec nos alliés arabes et avec toute la
communauté internationale parce que cet
ignoble monsieur kadhafi avait promis de
rayer benghazi de la carte
et si nous avions laissé les jeunes de
benghazi
massacrées par ce dictateur on aurait
fait exactement ce qui s'est passé à
l'époque de monsieur mitterrand lorsque
8000 musulmans ont été assassinés
devant une communauté internationale et
bailly est impuissante et parce que je
veux qu'on lutte contre l'islamisme
radical
je veux qu'on défende des jeunes
musulmans les biens qui descendaient
dans la rue non pas pour dire mort aux
juifs et aux américains
mais on veut du travail on veut de la
démocratie c'est quand même notre
civilisation qui est en cause et c'est
une merde commune excusez-moi la libye
me sens plus proche de l'europe que des
états unis d'amérique d'ailleurs lorsque
je quitte le pouvoir en mai 2012
la libye a des élections libres pour la
première fois de son histoire avec 65 %
de participation et ceux qui gagnent ce
sont les modérés et je ne comprends pas
et je n'accepterai jamais pourquoi la
communauté internationale et la france
ont laissé tomber la libye alors qu'il
fallait encadrer la libye aider la libye
qui avait un gouvernement de musulmans
modérés et qui avait pour la première
fois un gouvernement démocratique
est-ce que je dois rappeler aux français
qu entre 1789 et 1875 il nous a fallu
près d'un siècle qu'on a connu deux
empires qu'on a connus la terreur et
qu'on a mis un siècle avant d'établir la
démocratie dans notre pays
c'est malheureux libyen avait besoin
qu'on les aide on les a laissés tomber
et on les a laissés tomber
soit par indifférence monsieur obama
soit pour des raisons politiciennes
parce que l'intervention en libye avait
été engagé par le gouvernement que je
présidais mais à ce qu'il n'aurait pas
été convaincue par ce que je dis mais
qui me regardait la syrie si tellement
intéressant
dès août 2012 je sors de mon silence
tout le monde me tombe dessus
ce qui renforce ma conviction pour dire
tu t'en souviens je vous en supplie
intervenaient en syrie parce qu'à ceux
qui sont pas convaincus qu'une
intervention en libye alors vous allez
convaincu absolument de la
non-intervention syrie parce qu'à
l'époque nous parlons de août 2012 en
syrie vous avez une opposition
démocratique très forte qui n'est pas
dans les mains d'al qaïda vous n'avez
pas l'état islamique et aujourd'hui
parce qu'on a intervenu trop tard et
trop mollement trop tard et trop
mollement vous avez l'état islamique
vous avez al quaida vous avez bachar
el-assad et vous avez une opposition
démocratique qui s'est senti abandonné
par la communauté internationale et qui
est tombé dans les mains d'al qaïda
voilà le résultat de l'impuissance et du
refus d'intervenir cher et c'est la
vérité je ne dis pas à renault que
c'était facile c'est pas ça je dis pas
ça mais vous savez allons vers l'orient
compliqué avec des idées simples disait
le général de gaulle
en tout cas je peux vous dire une chose
la lâcheté l'impuissance l'incapacité à
prendre des décisions
ça n'a jamais amélioré la gestion d'une
crise partout dans le monde
il faut y aller et la vocation de la
france leader pas suiveurs alors c'est
passé encore que passé le présent je
souhaite que la france est une nouvelle
politique étrangère qui partent d'une
vision la vision jeu la firme c'est
l'expression d'une identité
le mot comme vous le savez ne me fait
pas peur dans l'identité de la france et
à l'appartenance à l'europe et que les
choses soient claires là aussi
jamais je n'accepterai que nous nous
séparions de l'europe
je vais j'y reviendrai mais enfin la
france a vocation à diriger l'europe à
l'idée l'europe a été à la tête de
l'europe c'est notre continent
ce sont nos racines ce sont nos valeurs
c'est notre identité
il suffit pour chacun d'entre nous de
quitter notre continent pour se rendre
compte qu'il est européen je veux
dire que cette identité c'est également
la famille occidentale
c'est une famille nous partageons les
mêmes valeurs de démocratie et quentin
soldats américains meurent partout dans
le monde
c'est un des nôtres parce que nous
sommes liés par le sang parce que nous
avons eu des guerres mondiales
parce que des jeunes américains sont
venus mourir chez nous pour nous sauver
et pour préserver notre liberté
je n'ai pas l'intention de traiter ça
qu'on fait en cela avec un groupe de rap
venant danser sur la mémoire de deux
millions de jeunes qui sont morts
donc je la firme dans l'identité dans la
vision que j'ai de la france nous
appartenons à la famille européenne et
nous appartenons la famille occidentale
c'est quand même pas on va quand même
pas nous accuser de dire qu'on est la
famille occidentale
c'est une famille bon avec des
américains nous partageons les mêmes
goûts pour les films la même musique
comment les mêmes écrivain et nous avons
temps ensemble
c'est une si une forme de civilisation
c'est des valeurs communes c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai voulu pour
rien trayons le commandement de
l'alliance atlantique
à l'époque les socialistes et monsieur
hollande s'était insurgé
quand il changé depuis rien rien et je
voudrais dire une chose qui me fait de
la peine c'est que jamais nous n'avons
été aussi soumis aux états unis aient
jamais l'influencent de la france sur
les états unis n'a été aussi faible
sa seule vérité
j'ai vu compris que monsieur baba dit
que j'ai même un tempérament n'était pas
facile c'est vrai c'est la france la
france est un allié fidèle mais la
france ne transige pas avec ses intérêts
avec ses amitiés
jamais la france n'a été aussi aligné
sur la politique des états unis
qu'aujourd'hui et jamais ne
l'influencent de nos dirigeants sur les
américains étaient aussi faible ce qui
est lié
parce que les américains il aime les
gens forts et respecte les gens forts il
n'aime pas les gens faibles ou les
politiques faire alors si on me le
permettait pour pas être trop long je
voudrais quatre priorités pour la
politique des affaires étrangères de
l'alternance la première des priorités
j'ai peut-être vous étonner mais c'est
une constante chez moi je crois que la
politique étrangère française doit avoir
une première priorité c'est la
méditerranée
je reste plus que persuadé que c'est en
méditerranée que se joue une grande
partie de l'avenir de la france de
l'europe hier philippe et du monde
ne vous trompez pas dans cette affaire
quand la france tourne le dos à la
méditerranée et ne tourne pas le dos à
son passé elle tourne le dos à son
avenir
la vocation de la france c'est d'assumer
un leadership très fort en méditerranée
le rapprochement la coopération des
peuples de méditerranée est plus que
jamais nécessaire
ça nous permettra d'avoir la capacité
d'aider l'islam à surmonter les deux
guerres qui la ronge qui le ronge
la première c'est les sunnites et les
chiites la france en grâce ne doit pas
choisir entre ryad et téhéran
la france doit parler avec les deux avec
la capitale des sunnites avec la
capitale des gîtes et à ceux qui me
disent qu'on doit parler ni à l'un ni à
l'autre alors cela veut dire qu'on fait
disparaître la france de la carte de la
méditerranée et du moyen orient
parce que si vous pensez que vous allez
résoudre les crises du moyen orient
sans parler à l'iran ils sont parlés à
l'arabie saudite sait qu'on n'a pas la
même expérience de la gestion des
affaires internationales la france doit
être un
où la france doit parler avec tout le
monde la france doit prendre
l'initiative de conférences
internationales pour essayer de résoudre
ce drame qui est l'affrontement entre
les chiites et les sunnites
c'est le rôle de la france la deuxième
guerre de l'islam où nous pouvons me
semble-t-il joué un rôle
c'est la guerre entre une majorité de
ceux qui vivent leur voix leur foi
pacifiquement et le terrorisme
djihadiste
je veux dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont si on décide de faire la guerre il
faut la faire pour la gagner et si on
veut la gagner il faut la gagner par
tous les moyens nécessaires il faut
aller là où le malletier adista pris
racine et se développe éradiquer
al-qaïda
éradiquée l'état islamique
cela veut dire prendre des initiatives
pour qu'en plus une coalition aérienne
qui fait plus on mobilise des forces
arabes pour aller sur le terrain jamais
vu une guerre qu'on pouvait gagner
uniquement dans les airs ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il faut envoyer des soldats
européens bien sûr que non pour ne pas
recréer les conditions d'un affrontement
entre l'orient joël et l'occident
évidemment mais la france peut être
leader là dessus comme elle l'a été en
libye s'agissant de la syrie
mais c'est la france qui doit rapprocher
les deux coalitions contre des ch et je
suis désolé quand le régime syrien et
ses soutiens ont repris palmyre il eût
fallu symétrie symétriquement une
offensive similaire pour reprendre aka
le fief de des en syrie parce que si on
veut qu'un rapprochement entre les deux
coalitions et bien il faut qu'elle soit
de force équivalente
il n'y aura pas de rapprochement si
l'une paraît moins déterminé que l'ofc
il une part est moins importante que
l'autre donc les pays de la région
doivent s'engager pour régler le drame
syrien et c'est l'ensemble du sud de la
méditerranée
nous devons aider à stabiliser la
tunisie je vous rappelle 780 km de
distance entre 10 et rick et tunis
c'est demain la tunisie devait tomber
parce qu'on n'avait pas assez aidés nous
en paierons des l'autre conséquence
c'est le roi du maroc
heureusement qu'on peut s'appuyer sur
lui c'est les algériens le prix du
pétrole crée les conditions d'une
explosion sociale
là-bas ce sont les jordaniens qu'il faut
soutenir et également les égyptiens donc
vous le voyez pour la france je souhaite
une priorité absolue la méditerranée ce
qui nous amènera sans doute apporté une
grande conférence internationale pierre
pour parler de la question des
constitutions des frontières et de la
réconciliation chiites sunnites
c'est un sujet majeur j'oserais dire
c'est même pas sujets de politique
étrangère dans ses proches de chez nous
j'ajoute un dernier point le problème de
la méditerranée et de lorient c'est le
problème de la diversité
lorient sans les juifs c'est plus
lorient lorient sans les chrétiens ce
n'est plus lorient et la question n'est
pas pour nous d'accueillir tous les
chrétiens d'orient
mais quand les chrétiens d'orient reste
en orient où ils sont victimes d'un
scandaleux génocide
abandonné par tout le monde est au
naturel en chine et ce deuxième priorité
de la politique étrangère de la france
pour moi c'est clair c'est l'afrique
non mais mais mes chers amis c'est très
important parce que l on quand on parle
des politiques étrangers en général on
parle de tous les sujets on survole mais
faut dire aux français ce qu'on va faire
l'afrique c'est une priorité absolue et
je souhaite que l'on repense
complètement notre relation
développement sécurité immigration sur
le développement il faut cesser de
considérer le soutien au développement
de l'afrique comme un acte de charité
c'est insupportable alain pourquoi j'ai
pas non pas que ce soit insupportable
d'être charitable mais face à na aucun
sens au moment où la population de
l'afrique va passer à 2 milliard et demi
d'habitants
2 milliard et demi d'habitants de
cinquante la seule afrique subsaharienne
en comptera 2 milliards en 2050
peut-être plus le nigeria sur le
troisième pays le plus peuplé de la
planète derrière l'inde est derrière la
chine
c'est très simple la population du niger
nigériens mais du niger en 2050 sera 20
fois supérieure à ce qu'elle était en
quand est ce qu'on a connu ça et on
vient me dire que le développement sénat
charité non non non le défi du continent
africain c'est d'offrir des emplois et
un avenir à sa jeunesse
bon aujourd'hui mes chers amis 40% de la
population africaine subsaharienne à
moins de 15 ans donc vous savez on n'est
pas dans la charité
nous devons poser les bases du plus
gigantesque plan de développement jamais
envisagé pour que l'afrique trouve les
moyens de stabiliser une population qui
si elle n'est pas stabilisée viendra en
europe où nous n'avons pas les moyens ni
en logement dit ni en finances ni en en
possibilités politiques d'ailleurs de
les accueillir alors on va me dire mais
en fait tu n'y penses pas les
conséquences budgétaires
oui oui bien sûr et bien moi j'invite
ceux qui regardent ça de manière
comptable à réfléchir aux coûts générés
par l'immigration illégale et au cou
militaire générés par la nécessité de
stabiliser un continent parce
qu'attention nous parlons d'une afrique
qui a 1 million 250 millions d'habitants
je parle de l'afrique de demain 15h à 2
milliards 500 millions
donc c'est à dire que les problèmes vont
plus que doubler
je crois à la nécessité d'un formidable
plan de développement financés par
l'europe sur lequel je men conditions
sexy c'est de l'argent européen il doit
revenir aux entreprises européennes et
je demande le changement des règles de
la concurrence
naturellement ainsi pierre et alain on
aurait les conditions d'un développement
de l'afrique de la croissance pour nous
et une possibilité de dire à nos amis
africains que pas un seul continent ne
peut résister avec des familles où la
natalité d'entre 6 et 8
faux je ne réclame pas des mesures
coercitives ça n'a jamais marché
mais enfin quand même on va pas
m'empêcher de décrire une réalité dont
personne ne parle et qui est une réalité
qui saute à nos yeux parce que j'ai
parlé du démarrage de l'afrique qui est
réel mais qui quelle quelle croissance
faut-il pour supporter huit enfants par
famille vous imaginez naturellement ceux
qui ignorent ce qui m'amène ou troisième
pilier avec l'afrique et l'immigration
nous devons construire un véritable
partenariat vous eh bien on refait une
politique de développement avec un plan
massif de développement et on parle
immigration va gérer ensemble ça veut
dire quoi
mais moi je demande que healy et un
conditionnement de notre politique du
développement en afrique à l'engagement
de l'afrique contre l'immigration
illégale
c'est un partenariat gagnant gagnant
parce que si vous croyez qu'on va
pouvoir contrôler l'immigration illégale
simplement d'europe l'europe à s'engager
pour le développement de l'afrique
l afrique va s'engager contre
l'immigration illégale voilà le
partenariat de demain entre l'europe et
l'afrique
je pense aux deux spots je voudrais dire
écoutez mettre des hotspots en europe
n'ont aucun sens parce que vous avez des
malheureux qui risquent leur vie en
traversant la méditerranée
ceux qui s'en sortent par miracle on
leur dit maintenant vous passez de
l'autre côté ce que vous ne croyez pas
qu'il serait plus cohérent de mettre les
hotspots dans les pays du sud ou dans
les pays qu'on appelle les pays de
rebond naturellement pierre on les
financerait nous-mêmes ça ne me pose
absolument aucun problème
je veux dire par ailleurs qui n'est pas
question de continuer la politique de
développement
nous donnons des centaines de milliers
de visas chaque année si nous n'avons
pas les visas de retour sains pour soi
les terroristes ne voulons pas soit les
étrangers en situation illégale qui
doivent être accueillis par le pays dont
ils sont partis il me semble que là on a
la deuxième priorité de la politique
étrangère française
troisième priorité j'en ai 4 c'est la
réforme de la gouvernance mondiale
on peut plus continuer comme ça le
marché mondial s'est installé sans qui
est une gouvernance
mondiale donc il s'agit d'avoir une
gouvernance du monde
adapter au xxième siècle est pas adapté
au 20e la réforme de l'onu
c'est absolument indispensable pourquoi
nous avons fait le g20
parce que l'onu ne marchait pas d'abord
parce qu'on peut plus continuer a décidé
à l'unanimité cantonné 199 pays et
d'autre part les mais chers amis il
suffit du bon sens il n'ya pas un seul
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
africain pinsolle il n'y a pas un membre
du coup de permanents au conseil de
sécurité indiens le pays le plus peuplé
du monde
il n'y a pas un membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité d'amérique du sud
accessoirement la même population que
l'europe
et quant au japon et à l'allemagne
naturellement ça compte pas ils ne sont
pas membres permanents pour la raison
simple qu'ils ont été du mauvais côté en
ça ne peut plus fonctionner ainsi
je souhaite une véritable réforme de la
gouvernance mondiale
c'est possible c'est indispensable
on va élargir le nombre de membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité et
chaque région du monde aura son propre
système de désignation
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir les mêmes en
europe en asie en afrique en océanie
ça n'a pas de sens je souhaite que dans
ce cas de la gouvernance mondiale la
france soit le pays leaders pour la
régulation de la mondialisation
car là encore je sais trés christian
intellectuelle est fantastique
le débat c'est mondialisation ou pas
mais non la modélisation est en fait il
ya sept milliards d'habitants sur la
planète il ya 70 millions de français
vous croyez que nous on va s'asseoir
bord du trottoir on va dire allez
continuer sont nourries vont continuer
sans nous ça va nous faire du bien
en revanche le thème de reconnaître la
mondialisation comme un fait
incontournable ne veut pas dire qu'on
accepte la mondialisation telle qu'elle
est
au contraire si vous reconnaissez la
mondialisation comme un fait
incontournable
vous devez porter une politique qui a
disparu des écrans radars depuis
quand qu'est la régulation de la
mondialisation régulation financière
régulation du prix des matières
premières ont fait écouter ça suffit
maintenant quand un bateau contenant du
pétrole entre le son port de départ et
son port d'arrivée la propriété change
dix fois bon sur les céréales les grands
de ce qu'on appelle les grandes cultures
la quantité physique de céréales a été
l'année dernière vendue 10 fois il ya
bien quelqu'un qui en profitent alors
j'ai des producteurs qui sont payés de
moins en moins cher des consommateurs
qui paient de plus en plus cher qu'est
ce qui dit que la spéculation à ce point
doit régner en maîtresse absolue et les
gouvernements incapables de réagir et
poser la moindre question
je suis désolé ça ne se passe pas comme
cela je crois à l'économie de marché je
crois l'offre à la demande mais quand on
vend 10 soit la même quantité physique
il ya peut-être des intermédiaires qui
en profitent bien au détriment des
producteurs d'un côté et les
consommateurs de l'autre la régulation
du prix des matières premières est
également essentiel et je vous annonce
que dans deux ans vous aurez une
explosion des prix du pétrole
vous le verrez parce que comme il ya une
réduction des possibilités de recherche
de gaz de schiste pétrole de schiste du
fait de la baisse du prix
aujourd'hui on va se retrouver avec une
impression de pénurie dans deux ans et
alors que les prix n'ont jamais été
aussi bas même si choses autour de 50
dollars sont baissé jusqu'à 30 demain
ils vont exploser
où est la régulation est ce qu'on peut
pas faire des stocks
est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir une
politique assurantiel est-ce qu'on peut
pas mettre de la transparence dans les
marchés
est-ce que c'est pas le rôle de la
france qui peut parler d'égal à égal
avec les plus grands et qui peut avoir
la confiance des plus petits que de
poser cette question est ce que le cacao
si important pour la côte d'ivoire le
prive en effet à londres parce que des
gens vont spéculer sur cette matière
première ou pas c'est quand même un
sujet absolument
majeur que la france doit apporter dans
sa politique étrangère
enfin dernier point sur la gouvernance
mondiale
je veux dire la démographie je ne
m'étendrai pas sur le sujet enfin
écoutez cette impression blabla c'est le
premier sujet y a pas plus important
c'est le premier défi de l'humanité il y
en a pas plus important je vous assure
réfléchis saisi il ya plus d'habitants
sur la planète qu'il n'y en a jamais eu
depuis l'origine il n'y a pas eu un
organisme qui on parle
il n'y a pas une conférence chaque année
pour voir comment vont les choses les
chinois viennent de renoncer à la
politique du un enfant parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à financer leur système
de de retraite
il ne s'agit pas mon dieu j'espère qu'on
ne fera pas ce ce procès de dire il faut
une seule politique de natalité sur la
planète c'est impossible
et d'ailleurs il ya des comptines
antivieillissement la russie excusez moi
la russie voit sa population diminuer un
peu moins un peu moins enfin disons que
si on regarde dérivant sur les 20
dernières années
je peux je peux confrontés les chiffres
je suis sûr qu'on a ça en tout cas on
peut pas comparer la natalité en russie
et dans d'autres pays mais comme why et
je demande la mise en place un homme
d'un organisme mondial qui étudie la
démographie et une conférence annuelle
sur l'évolution de la démographie et les
méthodes qui fonctionne qui ne sont pas
des méthodes coercitives naturellement
mais qui peuvent être le planning
familial l'information le développement
économique pour qu'au moins on sache on
sache quoi
combien d'habitants au maximum peut
vivre sur la planète
je vous rappelle les chiffres nous
serons plus de 11 milliards en 2100 quel
monde allons nous laisser à nos enfants
et je suis très étonné que cette
question de la démographie soit absente
des discours j'ai regardé d'à peu près
les discours à la dernière assemblée
générale des nations unies personne n'en
a parlé
enfin dernière priorité me semble-t-il
pour la politique étrangère de la france
la russie et la turquie
pour que poursuivre mon dialogue avec
pierre fructueux non la russie je veux
dire mon total accord avec si elle dit
j'aurai l'occasion de revoir le
président poutine
ce soir mes chers amis nous n'avons pas
besoin d'une nouvelle guerre froide
mais je voudrais juste en un mot quand
même dire à yalta à yalta nous avons
laissé tomber
c'est ça la vérité parce qu'on voyait le
scandale des harkis dont dont on a parlé
quand on est bien du mal à parler bien
du mal à parler qu'on a laissé tomber
mais à yalta nous avons laissé tomber
quoi 80 millions d'européens à qui on
avait promis des élections libres
excusez moi parce que 46 47 48 devait
être le lieu d'élection libre
évidemment c'est les gens dire que ces
vieux menace comme intéressant de savoir
d'où on vient et ces élections libres
ont lieu chez nous l ont pas eu lieu
c'est ce pourquoi parce que l'armée
rouge l'époque a pris possession et a
interdit les élections libres et on dira
jamais assez le nombre de centaines
digne de dizaines de millions de morts
dont est responsable le communisme dans
cette partie de la planète s'appelait
pas quand on le dit et pourtant c'est
une réalité historique qui est
incontournable
on les a laissés tomber ils se sont
libérés tout seul à partir de 1981
france a commencé avant dans ses termes
et disons 89
ils sont libérés tout seul c'est pas
nous tout seul ça veut dire qui c'est
jean paul ii
ce pape indomptables qui a porté le
message de toute l'europe de l'est à
partir de sa pologne ses valises à c'est
vaclav havel
je voudrais pas oublier tout un tas de
gens ils se sont libérés et le mur de la
honte parce que c'était le mur de la
honte est tombé à l'époque monsieur
mitterrand disait j'aime tellement
l'allemagne que je préfère qu 1 et 2 oui
mais l'habitait pas de l'autre côté du
mur parce que peut-être qu'il n'aurait
pas dit ça ce moment-là peut-être qu'il
n'aurait pas dit ça à ce moment là alors
je vous le dis je ne peux pas accepter
comme pierre l'idée qu'un nouveau mur
politique cette fois ci d'une guerre
froide dont nous ne voulons pas se
rétablisse entre la russie quel
continent européen
ce n'est l'intérêt de personne et
sûrement pas et sûrement pas des
polonais alors pierre qui a parlé du
sommet de varsovie dont je jouais
préciser que je ne suis pas content le
système d des anti missile d'ailleurs je
l'avais accepté lorsqu'on avait parlé je
crois que c'était au portugal en 2010
mais tu te rappelles que j'avais demandé
que le système des antimissiles on
prenne la peine d'associer les russes
d'associer les russes pour que les
russes ne pense pas que c'est un système
contre eux et ça a été complètement
abandonné pierre donc moi je ne veux pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
je considère que même si la menace
iranienne a un peu baissé en intensité
enfin on ne sait jamais on peut voir les
choses plus manière plus apaisée mais
l'association des russes aux systèmes
antimissiles c'est la bonne solution
naturellement quant aux nouvelles
divisions les blindés et ses côtés mes
chers amis franchement si avec des ch
avec al qaïda avec tous les problèmes
que nous avons à gérer on se met en plus
le problème d'un affrontement plus ou
moins larvé avec les russes c'est
vraiment qu'on cherche des ennuis
don dans tous les cas on aura à payer
l'addition il faut faire tous linverse
et je vais vous faire d'ailleurs une
proposition qui est très simple il faut
sortir du blocage aurait l'occasion de
la développer demain et d'essayer de
l'expliquer au président poutine
il faut créer un électrochoc positif
entre la russie et l'europe et pour moi
c'était trop cher positif pourrait être
la décision conjointe d'une levée
progressive et mutuelles des sanctions
en échange de gestes concrets de part et
d'autre allant dans le sens de
l'application de minsk aujourd'hui les
uns justifie qu'on n'applique pas mine
ce qui est la seule solution possible
pour l'ukraine parce qu'il ya les
sanctions
les autres disent on lève pas les
sanctions parce qu'il ya plaide pas
d'application de l'accord de minsk avec
ça dans dix ans on en sera exactement au
même point
sauf que ça sera aggravée parce qu'entre
temps les passions se seront
approfondies et je ne partage pas du
tout l'analyse des experts qui pensent
qu'avec du temps les crises se résolvent
avec lui du temps elles se compliquent
il faut bien mieux gérer une crise tout
de suite parce que c'est chaud mais au
moins vous pouvez porter le bistouri et
trouvé la solution on l'avait vu avec la
géorgie
donc je propose une chose très simple au
lieu de rester chacun de son côté qu'on
lève progressivement les sanctions est
en tout cas qu'on les fasse vote pas
pour six mois - qu'on fasse un geste
qu'on est peut-être dans trois mois mais
qu'on les lève progressivement et
partiellement et quand les changements
demandent au président poutine de faire
des gestes concrets pour l'application
de minsk pour qu'au lieu d'avoir une
logique de bloc contre bloc qui arrête
tout le monde on est une logique positif
et qu'on ne vienne pas me dire que parce
que je propose sage malines sur les
positions des russes en géorgie
vous souvenez très bien que je ne suis
absolument pas aligné sur les positions
des russes mais aussi amis que je suis
avec les américains c'est pas monsieur
obama qui décidera pour moi qui est
l'adversaire de la france ou qui ne
l'est pas que les choses soient claires
simples et précises
ou demain madame clinton ou le candidat
républicain un mot il y aurait tendance
à dire un mot pour terminer sur la
turquie
il a aussi je fais une proposition le
débat politique est tellement réducteur
j'ai effectivement toujours été opposé à
l'entrée de la turquie en europe je le
dis ce qui me caricature c'est tellement
facile de caricaturer vous savez c'est
tellement simple tellement plus
difficile d'avoir des idées j'aime la
turquie c'est toujours aimé ce pays et
je les visiter de fond en comble et ce
qui me permet de vous dire que la
turquie ont la visite pas des côtes
parce que la turquie est un continent la
turquie c'est la turquie de l'intérieur
et notamment la cappadoce qui signifie
auquel merveille la turquie ce continent
bien sûr l'empiré ottoman surmonter en
écosse on retrouve les traces partout
mais la turquie c'est l'asie mineure
donc ma conviction absolue c'est qu'il
faut discuter avec la turquie mais pas
la faire entrer en europe pourquoi la
thur tice est un bon un pont entre
l'asie et l'europe si vous coupez un
pont d'une rive ce pont n'a plus aucun
intérêt
d'ailleurs pour l'ukraine je fais la
même analyse l'ukraine est un pont un
pont entre la russie et l'europe il ya
30% de russophones en ukraine
si vous intégrez le cren dans l'europe
vous fait exploser ce pays
je vais donc proposer l'émergence d'un
nouvel ensemble qui pourrait réunir la
russie l'europe et la turquie
nous aurions ainsi un continent organisé
autour de trois cercles un premier qui
serait l'europe de l'euro avec les 19
pays qui révèrent plus d'intégration et
une meilleure convergence des politiques
est connu un second l'europe des 28 dont
je tiens tiens absolument à ce qu'on
intègre à terme les balkans si vous
aimez l'histoire
regardez ce qui s'est passé au début du
20e siècle et personne de raisonnable ne
peut proposer de laisser les balkans en
dehors d'une organisation politique
européenne
32-33 avec moins de compétences
une commission curé d'autres
responsabilités j'aurai l'occasion d'en
parler à des jeunes et le 21 avec mme
merkel à berlin en lui parlant de
l'initiative que nous prendrons de
déposer quel que soit le bric site ou
pas un nouveau traité européen pour
changer normes et un troisième élément
qui pourrait représenter 800 900
millions d'habitants qui ré de la
turquie à la russie en passant par
l'europe qui peut être demain d'ailleurs
pourrait être une solution d'accueil
pour l'ukraine la biélorussie ou dpi
ainsi je sais bien quand on est à kiev
je connais très bien kiev que c'est une
capitale européenne ont fait il ne reste
pas moins que l'ukraine sait pas qui est
simplement les 42 millions d'habitants
autant d'habitants comme qu'en pologne
où nous parlerions de quoi nous nous
parlerions de sécurité et de coopération
dialogue politique à très haut niveau
entre les trois membres fondateurs
turquie russie europe coopération
économique étroite ce qui ne signifie
pas marché comme un marché commun c'est
c'est une autre aventure coopération
économique et droite et par ailleurs
réflexion sur la sécurité commune
notamment contre notre ennemi commun qui
est le terroriste djihadiste et vous
verrez à ce moment là on pourra enfin
dire la vérité à la turquie parce que
les premières négociations d'adhésion de
la turquie à l'union européenne ce et
1964 63 63 parfait donc il est peut-être
temps d'arrêter l'hypocrisie de sortir
du chantage et des mensonges pour
regarder la situation telle qu'elle est
et proposer à nos amis turcs un
partenariat politique économique et de
sécurité dans un nouveau cadre et vous
voyez mes chers amis venus parler avec
trop de passion je le sais nos vins et
on a le droit d'être intéressés par ce
qu'on fait c'est pas c'est quand même
pas quand je pense qu'on voulait nous
interdire de réfléchir à notre projet
mon cher eric heureusement qu'on n'a pas
cédé encore une fois bon mais vous voyez
et vous voyez au travers de ses propos
de la sonitra et que vous avez organisé
merci encore quelle est la vocation de
la france la vocation de la france est
d'être leader de montrer la voie de
prendre des initiatives de surprendre
dosé de réussir ce matin avec le
président de notre groupe christian
jacob
j'ai rencontré les représentants de tous
les groupes parlementaires du du ppe
mais je vous assure qu'ils étaient
contents d'entendre que la france avait
désigné parce que excusez moi mais ouais
sont les idées c'est pas une question d'
arrogance française parce que pour moi
quand on est la france sacrée plus de
devoirs que de droits
il s'agit pas de dire qu'on a autant on
a plus de droits que les autres
il s'agit de dire qu'on a plus de
devoirs et j'estime qu'en mettant un
euro chine gagne sur la table un nouveau
traité parce que qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire si les anglais sortent on va s'en
satisfaire
on va continuer à discuter avec les
turcs une entrée improbable et accepter
que la deuxième économie d'europe s'en
aille
et bien moi je ne me résous pas et je
n'accepterai pas et que ce soit le
vinoux le out on aura sur la table un
nouveau traité européen
j'en parlerai avec madame merkel et
j'essaierai de construire les conditions
d'une collaboration avec les allemands
et c'est ça la france
alors un dernier bon après si il faut
que je prenne l'avion cette fois c'est
sûr bon et je le dis à pierre que nos
amis qui sont ici moi j'accepte tout à
fait le débat entre nous n'est pas
d'accord sur tout
alain on échange
joël mais c'est ce débat qui est
fructueux d'air moi même je suis pas sûr
d'avoir la vérité
ce fut passionné je fais des
propositions qu'on en débatte qu'on les
enrichissent et que les français soient
rassurés de se dire il ya des gens qui
aiment encore suffisamment la france
pour avoir de l'ambition pour leur pays
on est français vous êtes français
nous sommes français et nous ne voulons
pas que la france disparaissent voilà et
quand la france n'a plus d'idées elle
disparaît et quand la france n'a pas
diverger
elle disparaît voilà au fond c'est ma
conclusion m